we wash dishes this is our dish thing
it's our disk attain er we work it out
our clothes we hand washing across the
vibram old you come to use the bass line
we'll use it you have a bucket we're
gonna get four take our scooper and
scoop out whenever we have customer
that's cool
put it away and there you go
we have our bathroom we've been doing it
ever since they should I want to go
[Music]
talk about inequality
it all starts if people turn off your
water one thing is beyond debate is that
people cannot live without water - no in
my city that our governance could allow
human beings in 2014 not to have water
we're facing our decisions if we don't
get our fiscal house in order if you
look at the situation in Detroit and in
Flint Michigan that is not America
that's not civilization we should not be
a country that allows greed and allows
money to separate people for being able
to flush toilets let's be very careful
about making a doctrinaire statement
about whether or not water is a human
right because it may well be but how do
you pay for it
[Music]